Hi Mayuko! many thanks for inviting me here
at your channel, I really appreciate the invitation
And well, about me. My name is Jorge. Jorge Villalobos
I'm a software developer at Amazon
And I also have a YouTube channel
My channel is Latincoder
It is about software, tips, and sometimes tutorials
all is in spanish
And well, I liike dogs, movies, videogames
sometimes I like to do a little bit of sport
I also like to read science fiction and horror
my favorite authors are Isaac Asimov and Stephen King
and again.. I like dogs
dogs are awesome
And yeah, that's a little bit about me
yeah, about my background
I have basically been an engineer in IT(information technologies)
I started my major back at 2007 and gratuated in 2011
I started working at this industry in early 2012
Year since I started developing software
I've worked with Web technologies such as PHP or JavaScript
I also worked for a time with Android
I continued to work on software development for multiple companies
the most well known companies I've work so far
Are possibly Intel(Intel Corporation)
and currently Amazon
Starting to work at Amazon was basically after an entire process of "preparation"
I consider that for me this was about 6 months of studying
I previously had experience developing software however...
my objective in my career was to work for a company
that would  greatly involved with software development
and also that it was a company recognized for it
There were several companies in my sight for which I started preparing(Interview preparation)
all of them located in the US
fortunately after a long process of
interviews.. traveling
and studying
I managed to get in
and the method I used to prepare was
practically through a book which is called Cracking the Coding Interview
it is a book has advice
and algorythms problems for me to solve
it was particularly hard for me to learn this
because I feel that I didn't had a good background on algorythms
and in addition to that I also used
websites such as Hackerrank or Leetcode
basically any website were I could find coding problems, then solved them and uploaded them to check if they were correct
that's what I wanted to do
besides that, I also asked for help
I asked people to give me advice,
to interview me
so I could practice as much as possible
so I would do better at the real interviews
Actually this was my second attempt to get at Amazon
and.... apart from the attempts that I did at other companies
I think I did a lot better this time, and I'm very happy to be here
but yeah, in total it was more than..
about 6 months studying
and well, now here we are. Making the most out of it.
well, working at this
for so many years in Mexico
I have approximately 7 years of working experience
from which the majority was in Mexico
since 2012 when I graduated
For me, working in Mexico has been an incredible experience
where I have learned a lot because I worked for companies that did different things
I worked for an outsource that didn't do a lot of programming as such, but more like databases
I also worked for a company focused on web development
especifically websites
and I was working in both backend and frontend
using PHP  and JavaScript.
Then I worked for a Mexican startup where I had a very interesting experience
because I learned a lot in a very short time
where I worked with very smart people
even when a lot of years have passed
I still consider them to be really good
and the pace at work was very fast
At that job, just imagine
I was working from Android mobile apps, to Ruby on Rails
even Nodejs
and I learned from people who knew about statistics
when I didn't even know what working on statistics was like
but I learned from them
and worked on frontend to visualize the data that they worked on
it totally was an adventure
I'd even say it was like a rollercoaster
and then, in Mexico
speaking about some of the companies
there are many startups in Mexico City and Guadalajara
which are the cities I was living at
Also, there are  many large companies
for instance I worked for Intel, which as a large company
that you find in Mexico
but there are other companies, for instance in Guadalajara you can find Oracle
there's IBM
there's HP
Intel is also there, and companies that work mostly in software development
generally there are many software development companies
because, I assume
because of the commerce treaty with the US
Mexico is a country where it is cheaper for some companies
to develop software so that they can use it elsewhere
because of this, the companies I worked, in many occasions
have customers not only from Mexico
but also in the US and Europe
and even in other countries from latin america
because Mexico has positioned as a great place for software development
even in Guadalajara, we say that it is(Guadalajara) the Mexican silicon valley
thanks to all the software development companies that are established there
so which techonologies are used?
PHP, JavaScript, Nodejs
Android, iOS, for all that of apps, there is development
for cloud applicationes I have seen that they also use AWS
Google's Cloud platform
also Microsoft's Azure
all those technologies I have seen that are used in Mexico
on Latin America I wouldn't be so sure
because I only have Mexico's perspective
however I have looked online
what kind of jobs you can find
and software development is just everywhere
There will be web development positions for all countries
for someone that knows who to do a web app, or a mobile app
In every country, practically there is going to be work opportunities for that
I'm not so sure "how much" exactly in other contries
but in Mexico the market is strong for this
well, about coming here to the US
what made me do..
or what made me want, to do this trip
was basically the opportunity to be able to work for a company that
I consider has a strong presence in software development
For me working for a company such as Amazon was an objective I had for while
and just getting there
and being there, just like I am now
was like an accomplishment for my career
its a new phase for me
and I see that now like an opportunity
that I'm taking and is been totally worth it, because I'm learning something new every day
I definitely wanted to have this on my resume
I wanted to have that as part of my professional experience
and I wanted to proof that I met the requirements to work in that kind of company
It was hard for me
but wanting that
was what made me come here
to have the opportunity to work with other engineers from the US
or from other countries
with people that are amazing, and learning from them everyday
That's what I like
that's what makes me passionate about software
and been here is like
been able to accomplish that dream to learn from people that I believe is a lot smarter than I
and I have a lot to learn from them
and well, this opportunity
that's why I'm here, because of my passion for software development that brought me here
well, english I have learned it since I was a kid
when I was a kid, my parents made it possible for me to have a private teacher
for english classes
I remember I was about 9 years old
and also since that age
approximately 9 or 10 years
I was attending what we call a "bilingual" school
basically in latin-american countries
you will find schools
that will teach english
there you can find teachers that
have a high proficiency on English
and even teachers that are native English speakers
and topics or courses
will be taught in english
so at that young age we are strongly exposed exposed to english to learn it
and that's how I learned
later, when I was studying at the university, we didn't have many courses in english
however I already had that knowledge from when I was a kid and teenager
so the things currently do for it
is just like watching TV and movies
without subtitles and in english
and that helps me to keep my english fresh
although right know I have the opportunity to speak it all the time because I'm living in Seattle
but anyways, is just a bit of advice of something I do to keep my english tuned
especially when I lived in Mexico where I wasn't exposed to english on a daily basis
the adaptation phase is something that has always been hard
the first thing that has been hard for me to adapt, and that I keep working on it
is naturally the language and communication
to put this in perspective
if I was at Mexico
I was living in a city called Guadalajara
and also lived in Mexico city
and, there are many particular ways to express yourself and communicate even in spanish
like those "slangs" how people call them
those "expressions"
and basically
when you go from one place to another
were costumes change a bit, even if its the same language
if I had moved to a different city
I would probably had to go through an adaptation fase
because even words start to change
maybe "A" doesn't mean "A" anymore, but it means "B"
and I know this because when I lived in Colombia
and I moved to Mexico
I had to go adapt, because a lot of times, even with the same language
I couldn't understand other people
I also experienced this for 6 months studying in Spain
also I didn't understood some people, even when it was the same language, Spanish
because it was spoken differently, different words were used
Now imagine this with english in the US
we have the factor of costumes
but also language
plus being talking in a different language all the time
I was exhausted because I wasn't used to do it all day long
and that obviously started to affect they way I communicated with my colleagues
I had to put a lot of attention of what was being said
Had to review anything discussed in meetings
asking multiple times to a colleague what was said
just to make sure that I could understand things at 100%
so that was the first thing I started
to struggle a bit in this adaptation process
the second thing, was mostly in the technical aspect
obviously for me, starting at Amazon was a leap in technical skills
required to be able to do my work, and
what can I tell you, I have to learn something everyday which is very exciting
but when I see the level of skill that people have
I have had to put more effort than usual
more than I considered "normal" effort
so that I can get to the same level as my peers
it started being a daily struggle, but little by little, moving forward
is like
is very reassuring when you start feeling that
you are now able to do things that have value for the team
However getting there has been difficult for me, even now
and I think it's part of the adaptation because doing this, is also
linked with communication
it's not the same thing adapting and ramp up
uhm, in your native language
than doing it in a different language, so everything is connected
well the visa thing in detail is super complicated
but basically what they are
it's a piece of paper, a document
is some kind of permit that a country provides you in order to
be able to visit that country, this if you are not originally from that country
the United states is a country for which
some other countries require a visa
permission so that you can access
or visit it legally
and there are visas of many types, there are tourist visas..
..visas for students
there are also work visas, among other kinds of visas
so for a person like myself
holding both Mexican and Colombian citizenships
I had different options.
Mexicans and Canadias for isntance, can apply to a special visa
named TN visa
that belongs to the NAFTA agreement between these 3 countries
you can apply to a TN visa
if you have a bachelor's degree
and by working on certain professional industries
like tech industry,
so that you can work at the US
Requirements are not that much
and it is easier to get this visa than other visas for other countries
In my case, I got my visa as a Colombian, for which I applied for a visa called H1B.
Basically you participate in a lottery
and basically you need to have
a bachelor's degree and certain amount of working experience
so that you can apply to that kind of visa.
There are other options, for example, there's the L1 visa
I think basically this is a visa that you get if you work for a company
that has branches in different countries
and such company has a branch in the US
it is possible, after working for a specific amount of time in this company
they can move you from one country to another.
So it can be possible that they transfer you from your country of origin where you are located
to the United States, so that's another of the existing methods.
there's another possibility that I haven't personally confirmed but
I've been told this can be an option.
this needs more investigation, but essentially it is to come to the US as a student
and while studying here, look for the possibility to get a work permit.
of course you have to do your own research
with a lawyer or someone that can confirm
because immigration laws can be really broad
and they're always changing
so you always have to ask for help
to understand the whole process.
As an individual who is simply here for work
I recommend that you look what are the options
and look for a company that will support you with
all the immigration process when they offer you a job opportunity
what advice could I give to people who'd like to
work here at the US and
specifically in techology?
The first one is mostly when you are speaking english
or want to improve your english
Take in consideration that the important thing is to communicate and
if you can sustain a conversation
that is enough.
Don't be afraid to start taking interviews,
if your english is not perfect, if it's not a native english, but
you are able to hold conversation,
a technical conversation.
Even if you speak slow, even if you speak with a few mistakes.
If the other person can understand what you are trying to say,
Then that means you made it.
Go ahead
Second tip is that you should know what are the requirements, or at least
inquire on the requirements for applying to a visa.
Depending of your country of origin, there may be different types of visas you may apply
and it is worth looking into it.
In my case I would have been able to apply for a TN visa
which is only available for Mexico and Canada.
But there is another kind of visa like the H1B
that allows you to work here in the US
But that one has different requirements, so we have to look them up and learn them
so that we know what we need, this can vary depending on the country
it can even vary depending on the kind of profession you have.
The third tip that I'll give for when
you want to come to work at the US
this one is quite personal
is that you need know very well
what kind of company you want to work for.
Generally there are going to be companies
like the ones I wanted to work for
big companies
companies that help you with all of the immigration process
companies that give you certain recognition
that you know that they are going to support you
and will help you on everything you need
I would recommend to look for companies like that
but there is also a great number of companies that try to
sponsor, to help
make possible for you to come here
by following the process to get a visa.
So you have to look for companies that provide sponsorship
it doesn't have to be the biggest
or the best company.
And also you have to be passionate about what you want to do
because when you come here you come with a commitment
to be in the company for certain period of time, because they make an investment in you.
And basically all that, relocating you
is a bet, that you must make worth it for the company
So look up what are the companies that you'd like to work for and
also support you on this
once you find those companies,
its time to start applying
Also don't be afraid,
it's just another country
it's not like a super radical change.
It is just a change, but
we are human and we can adapt to almost any situation, so there's no need to be afraid.
Well, on the Internet you can find me on my youtube channel which is
Latincoder, in my twitter that is @jorge_vgut
and in my instagram that is @jogeavi
and finally Mayuko, to conclude
many thanks for the invitation
to be here, I really appreciate that
I hope these answers were useful